Hey guys
I'm Nate welcome back to the workshop, you know that here at the King of Random we like weapons and we love weapons you can
build yourself but we especially love weapons that you can build yourself with supplies that you probably already have.
The purpose of today's video is to learn how we can make some darts with stuff we might already have lying around the house
What we're going to use to build these darts today is some toothpicks a little bit of tape some large needles a ball of string and some post-it notes.
If you don't have any large needles you can try
substituting them for other types of straight pin or even a small nail if you cut the head off
to start let's grab four of our toothpicks.
Next let's get a little bit of our tape, i'm using electrical tape and i like it because it's stretchy which makes it really bind
things together well if you've pulled it tight. You don't have to use electrical tape you should be able to just use masking tape or
duct tape let's take one of our toothpicks and stick it onto the end of our tape
we want the tape to be much closer to one end than the other leaving everything from about the middle of the toothpick down
Untaped with the toothpick stuck to the tape roll at once so the tape is going all the way around the toothpick at least once
once it's well wrapped in the tape let's take our other three toothpicks
bundle them right next to that first toothpick and then wrap the tape around all four together
we want to make sure we pull the tape really nice and tight around these toothpicks that will help them stay together a lot better
let's just set down our tape two toothpicks for a second and get some of our string what i'm using is just some basic cotton
string it's nice and strong and pretty lightweight
let's cut off a piece about a foot maybe a foot and a half long it doesn't really matter because i'm giving myself
extra that i'll end up cutting off later
now that we have our string let's place the end of the string
In the tape next to the toothpicks with our string attached to our tape we want to wrap it around the toothpicks one or two
More times to really secure it in place now let's cut off the tape
seal the edge down there we go we've got four toothpicks all well taped together
with a little over a foot of string taped into the bundle as well at this point let's grab our large needle and fit the
wide end into the gap in the middle of the four toothpicks
press it in as far as you can get it to go without breaking the toothpicks
It should push down until the widest part of the needle is just starting to go into where the tape is
with the needle in place now we need to start wrapping the string
around the ends of the toothpick we want to pull the string quite tight as it goes up the
Toothpicks near the points it will pull them together and that will secure our needle in place so it can't pop out
you
Can see that the four tips of the toothpicks have all started to taper inward and are resting up against the body of the needle
Once we reach the tip of the toothpicks let's wrap the string back down it doesn't have to be quite as tight
So i'm just going down much faster than a wind pop you can see that the string is a lot more spaced out
moving away from the point of the toothpicks
our string which is attached to the toothpicks by the tape in the middle is now wrapped around the tips of the toothpicks and then
back down around the string and the tape
We now want to take a little bit more tape and wrap it around the string once again to secure it all in place
This part of the string is extra so let's snip it off
Most of the body of our dart is now built but it needs some fins on the back to stabilize it as it flies through
the air to make our fins let's grab one post-it note fold the post-it note in half
so that one end meets up perfectly with the other end
Crease the paper and then unfold it we now want to fold it the exact same way in the opposite direction
our paper has now been folded lengthwise and widthwise
Although on a square piece of paper the length and width are the same thing so now what we want to do is flip our
paper over and fold it two more times but this time along the diagonal
And because it is opposed to note it's sticking, to itself a little bit but that's fine we just peel it apart
fold it the other direction
there we go our paper has now been folded four times which is giving us eight lines radiating from the center
what
We want to do is take the four concave folds and bring them down to meet each other in the center
we now have this nice pyramid shape made out of our folded paper
let's take the toothpicks and put one toothpick into each quadrant of our folded paper
at this point our dart should be ready to fly but these fins are a little big for my taste at this size they're going
to add a noticeable amount of drag which will limit how far our dart will fly so let's take them off trim the
and put them back on to trim your fins just fold any two of them together
until you have a triangle now let's just cut off a strip of paper from the bottom of our triangle
Fins are smaller so we can put them back in between the toothpicks
there you have it just like that you have a dark that should fly nicely and stick right into your target
these little homemade darts should be able to fly a pretty good distance
i'm not a great shot i think we've already established that
hmm not bad i got an eight beautiful
Nice attach a few balloons to a board and you have yourself a homemade carnival game
well
if that doesn't win me a prize nothing will these are full-size
balloons which i've only blown up halfway which means the very bottom of the balloon isn't
Stretched very much so i was actually able to puncture
The balloon
without it popping i'm just gonna leave that dart there for now
I don't know if anyone has ever pulled that off before in the history of darts and balloons oh?
No a very small hole in it now and it's just slowly eking out gasps a dead man walking
Ha now there is one more thing i want to try let's
See if this will work and yes i'm intentionally not saying what it is quite yet start the same way
or bundle together
let's give ourselves a little bit more string this time this is a little
Over two feet out guests tape that on the same way we did before
make sure it's on there nice and tight
wide end of the needle goes in between the four toothpicks
press it down till it's really on there now we wrap our string make sure it's nice and tight
working our way up the toothpicks but this time instead of turning around once we get to the tip and just
Wrap it a little bit more out onto the needle
A fair amount for an eel covered
there go now quickly work my way back of tape hold that down again just
like before let's cut off our extra string
now, you can see that the body of this dart is a little bit different we've got string just wrapping all the way up to
near the tip of it one other little change let's take some metal tape and
wrap that around all but the very end of our wrap string
we don't need to keep wrapping after that so let's cut off the extra
let's reattach these fins just the same as they were before
Now quick test to see if this dart will still fly
it does
wonderful so now with our specialized dart we're going
To see if we can light it on fire?
i've got this excessively large container of lighter fluid let's see if we can pour just a little bit of it onto the cotton wrap
tip of our dart oh
Okay well that's completely soaked and i only dripped about one drip down onto the table so i'm gonna call that pretty good
Now i have applied a piece of aluminum foil to our foam board and that's what i'm gonna try and hit so that if it
Does stay on fire all the way to the board it doesn't immediately try and catch the styrofoam on fire
Here goes nothing let's see if this will actually stay lit all the way to the board
You have a fire dart here goes oh?
went out
it lit on fire that part was good try this one more time
it doesn't stay lit
All right basically my last idea is i tied a whole bunch more string on to the end of this so
this doesn't work
I'm giving up and won't even you'll never even see this
It worked it worked or dewart it's on fire still ha i'm just gonna blow it out
so don't just melt off boards probably melting behind it
fire dart ah fire dart was working it was on fire when i hit the board yes
behind a dot
fire dark fire dart ha ha ha
Sorry i have to blow it out really quick just because it's i'm
fairly certain it's just melting the foam behind the foil immediately practical applications that i can think of zero
entertainment factor i don't know what's the scale
99.5, is fantastic i'm doing it again fire dog to the rescue
not sure what you're rescuing with fire dart
fired are
out it's really warm
It heated up the metallic tape around it so it's now maybe a little too hot to hold but fire dart it worked
Ha ha ha ha
There you go that's how you can make some darts using supplies you might already have around the house and with a little bit of
modification you can also make yourself a fire dart which is a ton of fun although not very practical
thanks for joining us for this project and we'll see you the next one talk to you then
paint that's leaking
hey guys i know there are so many great videos and great youtubers out there that you could be watching instead of the king of
Random, so i just want
To say how grateful i am that you choose to watch us
we're constantly doing everything in our power to bring you the best content we can make so truly just want to say thanks